pour les besoins de l'histoire de leur
histoire il fallait que je sois fachos
salon et pour couronner le tout escroc
eh bien je crois et je suis sûre même
que les français qui liront ce livre
auront une toute autre idée de moi
l'ancien conseiller sulfureux condamné
en 2014 pour avoir enregistré nicolas
sarkozy à son insu décrit un ancien
président manipulateur et franchement
pas tendre avec ses collègues
je sais bien que je suis le tom cruise
du pauvre mais enfin gérard larcher
ministre ce n'est pas possible il est
trop laid au fond c'est lamentable c'est
méprisable
je n'irai pas plus loin l'ancien chef de
l'état aurait eu des mots très durs
envers ses collaborateurs
françois fillon un pauvre type christian
estrosi un abruti avec une noisette dans
la tête
françois baroin un second rôle le crédit
que j'accorde à ce personnage assez
méthode empruntée à la stasi je porte
quelque chose de vrai dans dans ce livre
c'est ce qui est passé c'est l'opinion
sur estrosi qui l'aurait elle qui
l'aurait pois chiche dans la tête ça me
parait scientifiquement prouvé il peut
dire n'importe quoi n'importe comment
dans n'importe quel bouquin dans
n'importe quelle interview ce crédit les
taux entre zéro et moins l'infini il
paraissait quelqu'un qui a été très
intéressé aussi très très affairistes
dents quand on voit son histoire c'est
quand même pas une victime
un nouvel élément ressurgi dans la
sphère du financement les biens de sa
campagne
oui un carnet de notes qui mentionnerait
une série de versements profit nicolas
sarkozy juste avant l'élection
présidentielle de 2007 marché celui qui
aura appliqué à la politique
le principe de la pyramide de ponzi a
cumulé les sur promesse en période
électorale avec la ferme intention de
maintenir
aucune une fois au pouvoir et ce carnet
appartenait un ancien dignitaire du
régime de mouammar kadhafi retrouvé mort
à vienne en 2012 pensez pas que c'est
nicolas sarkozy qui l'a noyé dans
j'irais pas jusqu'a leur nom mais vous
savez aujourd'hui plus limite n'a pu
l'imiter quelque chose qui se passe
c'est de la faute de nicolas sarkozy
sondage tel écart entre les tours 5 en
avance nicolas sarkozy a écouté
attendant le prochain qui sera peut-être
mauvais on ses collants pendant une chez
lui au puy-en-velay qui lui ont même
valu de se faire chambrer au conseil
régional
je vous ai vu à la fête de l'oiseau dans
ceux d'antan ce magnifique petit collant
la dette alors qu'alain juppé confirme
son statut de favori à quelques mois de
l'élection présidentielle et accroît son
avance sur nicolas sarkozy
selon les derniers sondages il est de
moins en moins bordelais c'est du moins
ce que reprochent les élus de
l'opposition municipale au maire de la
ville alain juppé
en dépit de vos tentatives de séduction
je ne suis pas preneur nous sommes tenus
de faire un projet municipal tous les
trimestres et je m'interroge sur le
point de savoir si on ne veut pas passer
à ce régime puisque ce serait bon pour
notre santé à tous
ça vous est de faire baisser les taux
d'adrénaline donc voilà quatre fois par
an ça serait assez plat sucré qu'en ce
qui concerne en tout cas pour voir
certains d'entre eux vous avez raison je
suis pas je suis paillasson passé non
plus mais je joue on s'appelle ajout du
fleuret - 06
tu